all right silver state schools credit
union the sponsors of this next segment
it's back to talk about how they're
helping make back to school a happy time
here's mercedes with more
we are so happy to welcome that scott
arkles from silver state schools credit
union to the show scott for decades
silver state schools credit union you do
something really cool you encourage
students
with
these budding artists with the happy
times calendar contest how does that
work
yeah rasheed thanks for having us back
and and i
really want to tell you this is really
one of my favorite times of year and uh
and really i love this program because
what it represents is uh our area
students and also
anyone in the grades key through 12
being able to participate and so
students can submit artwork depicting
what makes them happy and the winning
submissions are then showcased in our
annual happy times calendar for members
and our community to see and enjoy
so one winner from each grade level we
will receive a hundred dollar cash prize
and their original artwork will then be
framed to commemorate their achievement
and oftentimes what we do to uh mercedes
is to post these things in our branch
offices and so it's it almost uh acts as
a uh
almost a
member
commemorative for them and so it's
really neat for them um well the
submission deadline for the 2023 happy
times calendar is september 30th so that
will be here before we know it and
details are available on our website at
silverstatecu.com
happy times it's so incredible how
talented these students are and
what you do to give them this platform
is so great and speaking of students
silver state schools credit union they
just held their annual back-to-school
supply drive again this year how did
that go thanks for asking mercedes our
annual back-to-school supply drive was a
great success again this year it
supports our local community and
directly benefits our focus schools so
our focused schools are rex bell
elementary and stanford elementary from
ccsd in addition we deliver back to
school supplies for the girls
empowerment middle school um also known
as gems and that's an all schools
non-profit public charter med middle
school for grades six through eight
and uh thanks to the combined donations
from our members in the community the
people over province foundation was able
to make these much needed donations to
our local students and so a big thank
you goes out to everybody who donated a
big thank you goes out to you because
you guys are always doing stuff in the
community what other community
initiatives do you have in the works
right now so we're planning actually a
food drive a clothing drive and even a
toy drive by the end of the year and so
i'll tell you more as we get closer to
those events
and we are excited to hear about them
and help in any way possible silver
state schools credit union is fantastic
i'm a member my daughters are members
and we're proud to say that we belong to
such a great organization thank you so
much scott we appreciate you too
mercedes thank you
thank you again to silver state schools
credit union for sponsoring this segment
for more information just call
702-733-8820 or visit
silverstatecu.com las vegas now we'll be
right